If you don't stop the wealth of the
wealthiest from spiraling upward as very
quickly, there will it will inevitably
lead to the disappearance of middle
class wealth and and also disappearance
of government wealth. That is what will
happen. Really, we need to tax these
people much much much more. I think we
need to be looking at inheritance tax on
very large estates. I think you know
sometimes when I say things like that,
people turn around and say, "Oh, but
they don't have the money in cash.
They'll have to sell the assets."
If all of the assets are owned by the
rich and the rich never sell their
assets, then working people will never
get assets. It's not rocket science. You
need the rich to sell that. This is
this. How else do you get your assets
back? You know, and I know people say,
"Oh, you don't live in a zero sum
economy. Build more. Build more. Build
more." Every government for 25 years has
tried that. It doesn't work. It doesn't
work. If you you have to keep an eye on
that distribution.